hasta ahora nuestro estudio de los
radicales ha consistido tan solo en la
raíz cuadrada hemos visto que si escribo
el signo radical como este y pongo un 9
dentro de él esto significa la raíz
cuadrada principal de 9 la cual es 3
positivo o puedes verlo también como la
raíz cuadrada positiva de 9 ahora lo que
está implícito cuando lo escribimos así
es que estoy tomando la raíz cuadrada
esto también lo podría haber escrito de
la siguiente manera el signo es radical
y aquí un índice 2 que significa la raíz
cuadrada la raíz cuadrada principal de 9
encuentra algo tal que si elevó ese algo
al cuadrado obtengo 9 este signo radical
no se aplica únicamente para la raíz
cuadrada puedes cambiar el índice aquí
para indicar con ese número el orden de
la raíz que se está tomando por ejemplo
si te preguntara cuál es esta raíz
esta raíz que puedes imaginarte que se
llama raíz cúbica o también la raíz de
tercer orden de 27 cuales está bien esta
es un número que si lo elevó a la
tercera potencia obtengo 27 bueno el
único número que si lo elevó a la
tercera potencia obtengo 27 es igual a
33 por 3 por 3 3 por 3 por 3 es igual a
27 3 por 3 9 por 3 27 ahora hagamos un
par bueno déjame hacer otro como estos
supongamos que a 16 déjame hacerlo en
otro color tenemos 16 y queremos extraer
la raíz cuarta de 16 si no se te ocurre
inmediatamente cuál es la raíz cuarta de
16 siempre podemos extraer los factores
primos de 16 veámoslo 16 lo podemos
escribir como 2 por 88 como 2 por 4 y 4
como 2 por 2
es decir la raíz cuarta de 16 en la raíz
cuarta de dos por dos por dos
hemos obtenido 2 multiplicado por sí
mismo cuatro veces es decir dos a la
cuarta y la raíz cuarta de dos a la
cuarta es simplemente dos podemos decir
que esto es algo así como la cuarta raíz
principal pues si estos dos es fueran
negativos también obtendríamos el mismo
resultado esto es similar a lo que pasa
con las raíces cuadradas así como se
tienen múltiples raíces cuadradas
también se tienen múltiples raíces
cuartas pero el signo es radical indica
la raíz principal ahora habiendo visto
esto hemos simplificado las típicas
raíces cuadradas anteriormente ahora
espero que podamos simplificar raíces de
mayor potencia probemos con un par de
ejemplos supongamos que quiero
simplificar la raíz quinta de 96 y como
mencioné anteriormente lo que hay que
hacer es factorizar 96-96 es igual a 2 x
48 lo cual a su vez es 2 por 24 lo cual
a su vez es 2 por 12 lo cual a su vez es
2 por 6 lo cual finalmente es dos por
tres
así es que esto es igual a la raíz
quinta de 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 2
por 2 por 2 por dos por dos
y por tres por tres otra manera de ver
esto es considerarlo como una potencia
racional con una potencia fraccionada ya
hemos hablado de esto es decir esto lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 3 elevado
a la potencia un quinto déjame poner eso
claramente por acá sacar la raíz enésima
de un número es equivalente a elevar ese
número a la potencia 1 entre en estas
dos expresiones aquí son equivalentes
así que sí aquí estás tomando esto a la
potencia un quinto este lo mismo que 2
por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 elevado al un
quinto por 3 a la un quinto ahora que
tenemos aquí aquí tenemos dos que se
multiplica asimismo 5 veces 2 a la
quinta elevado al un quinto se
multiplican los exponentes por lo cual
esto es igual a 2
así es que esto de aquí es igual a 2 y
esto aquí es 3
a la potencia un quinto dos por tres a
la potencia un quinto así es como
simplificamos la raíz quinta de 96 es lo
más que se puede simplificar o si
quisiéramos escribirlo en su forma
radical esto lo podemos escribir como 2
por la raíz quinta de 3 así tal cual
hagamos otro hagamos otro ejemplo
vamos a incluir ahora variables
supongamos que queremos simplificar la
raíz sexta de 64 x al octavo resolvamos
primero para 64 64 lo podemos escribir
como 2 por 32 lo cual es 2 por 16 lo
cual es 2 por 8 lo cual es 2 x 4 que es
2 por 2 es decir tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 2 a
la sexta por lo que esto es igual a la
raíz sexta de 2 a la sexta 64 estos a la
sexta por equis a la octava potencia
ahora la raíz sexta de 2 a la sexta
bueno eso es inmediato eso es igual la
raíz sexta de dos a las ex texto que
tenemos aquí es igual a 2 directamente
que multiplica a que multiplica a
la raíz sexta de x al octava la raíz
sexta de x a la octava potencia y cómo
podemos simplificar esto bueno esto es
lo mismo que estoy aquí lo mismo que x a
la sexta por x al cuadrado tenemos la
misma base entonces se suman los
exponentes 6 más 2 es igual a 8 por lo
que esto es igual a 2 por la raíz sexta
de x a la sexta por x al cuadrado ahora
la raíz sexta de quizá la sexta esto de
aquí la raíz sexta de quizá la sexta
simplemente x por lo que esto es 2 por x
que multiplica a la raíz sexta de x
cuadrada ahora esto lo podemos
simplificar aún más si nos fijamos en el
radical en esta expresión del radical
raíz sexta de x cuadrada es equivalente
a x cuadrada elevada a la un sexto esto
es exactamente lo mismo y si recordamos
las propiedades de los exponentes
sabemos que aquí
multiplican los exponentes por lo cual
tendríamos x elevado a la 2 por un sexto
vamos a escribirlo así tal cual x a la 2
por un sexto y esto va a ser igual a
bueno para que no se me olvide deja de
bajar el 2x arrastramos el 2x de arriba
así que esto es igual a 2x que ya hemos
bajado de arriba que multiplica a x a la
2 por un sexto es x a la dos sextos o si
simplificamos el dos sextos este lo
mismo que 2x por equis a la 2 sextos en
su mínima expresión
esto es x elevado a la potencia un
tercio o si lo escribimos en su forma
radical esto es igual a 2 x 2 x que
multiplica a la raíz cúbica de x la otra
manera de hacer esto es retomando lo
desde acá arriba esto que tenemos aquí
es equivalente
vamos a ignorar esto que hicimos aquí
previamente esto equivale a 2 porque
tenemos aquí x a la octava elevado a la
un sexto la raíz sexta de x a la octava
es x a la octava elevada a la un sexto y
esto que es igual a dos por equis
elevado a la ocho sextos dos por equis
elevada a la ocho sextos simplificamos
ocho sextos para tener dos por equis
elevado a la cuatro tercios y esto que
tenemos aquí es equivalente a lo que
tenemos aquí porque es eso bueno porque
aquí tenemos dos por equis a la potencia
1 x x sale un tercio si sumamos los
exponentes uno más un tercio obtenemos
cuatro tercios espero que te haya sido
interesante este pequeño tutorial sobre
raíces de orden superior creo que es muy
útil descomponer en factores primos y
darte cuenta de que si estás buscando
una raíz sexta tienes que tener un
factor primo que se repite por lo menos
seis veces en fin espero que hayas
encontrado esto más o menos útil